hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live Niger galt als stabil als Letzter
Start im Sahel nie Niger eine
demokratisch gewählte Regierung ein
enger Partner Deutschlands und jetzt gab
es einen Putsch hat auch in Niger das
Militär übernommen das Auswärtige Amt
hat nun eine Reisewarnung ausgesprochen
red einen deutschen zur Ausreise
frankreich hat eine Evakuierungsaktion
gestartet und hat auch angeboten
deutsche auf diesen Flügen mitzunehmen
die Sorge vor einer Eskalation nach
diesem Putsch ist groß und deshalb heute
bei uns Thema Evakuierung aus Niger wie
das ablaufen wird über die Lage vor Ort
und eben auch die Auswirkungen die
dieser Putsch auf die Sicherheit in der
gesamten Region auch insbesondere
natürlich in dieser selbst haben wird
das ist heute bei uns Thema kommentiert
live mit stellt Fragen direkt im Stream
oder auch per Mail viele von euch kennen
das schon mir liefern euch hier
Einschätzung Hintergrund und vor allem
auch Informationen vor Ort denn wir
schalten jetzt live in Hauptstadt von
Niger nach niami dort ist uns
zugeschaltet Gregor Robak Wert er ist
der Leiter der Landesdirektor von Aktion
gegen Hunger vor Ort für uns in Niger
hallo schönen guten Tag Herr oberquerth
am Wochenende färben die Bilder gesehen
gab es Proteste in der Hauptstadt dort
wo sie jetzt auch gerade sind gab es
auch Attacken auf die französische
Botschaft Niger eine ehemalige
französische Kolonie wie ist die Lage
jetzt ganz im Moment bei ihnen gerade
wir haben alle die Bilder gesehen was am
Wochenende passiert ist das war
tatsächlich auch die erste große
Versammlung mit einem Maß der
französischen Botschaft
dort ist die Situation wie wir sehen
eskaliert
tatsächlich ist das einzige was in der
Zeit passiert ist es gab letzte Woche
noch eine große Demonstration vor dem
Parteibüro des Präsidenten bazoom
wo auch 15 Autos angezündet worden die
Bilder haben wir auch gesehen
tatsächlich ist die Lage in ihrem ruhig
ich war gestern seit letzten Mittwoch
das erste mal wieder in unserem
Landesbüro und hatte abends nach der
Arbeit die Möglichkeit ja kurz durch die
Stadt zu fahren noch kleine Einkäufe zu
erledigen und zu meinem Erstaunen gibt
es keine besondere Militärpräsenz oder
Polizeipräsenz vor Ort das Leben ist
eigentlich wie immer die gleichen
abendlichen Staus der gleiche Verkehr
das gleiche Routen man hat das Gefühl
als hätte einen einen Machtwechsel als
Staatsstreichen nicht stattgefunden das
ist für uns alle unverständlich es ist
eine ganz ganz komische Situation mit
wenig Informationen die nach außen
fließt die wir auch bekommen
wir versuchen natürlich so viel wie
möglich Informationen zu zu generieren
und dann auch zu bewerten
wie wir weiter mit der Lage im Land
umgehen können verhalten sie sich
irgendwie anders jetzt als weißer Mensch
als offensichtlich ein Mensch aus dem
Ausland zurzeit was was bedeutet das für
sie jetzt gerade in dem Moment sie sind
zu Hause da erreichen wir Sie und was
bedeutet das für ihr Leben ihre Arbeit
tatsächlich so dass mich am
Mittwochmorgen aufgewacht und hat die
ersten Nachrichten bekommen über diesen
Staatsstreichen war völlig erstaunt weil
sich das auch nicht angekündigt hat also
niemand hat damit gerechnet hier vor Ort
und
wir Aktion gegen den Hunger wir haben
dann klare ablaufprotokolle ich habe
damit unsere Hauptbüro also ich arbeit
Spanien madritze gesprochen wir haben
dann einen Krisenstab eingerichtet und
ich habe umgehend ein Ausgangssperre vor
allen Dingen für die Auslands
Mitarbeiter verhängt also jeder muss das
Büro verlassen und auch nach Hause gehen
und das war dann auch
[Musik]
stabilisiert normalisiert kann ich auch
wieder ganz normales Büro zurückgehen
kann meine Arbeit und so
wir sprechen gleich noch weiter über
eben die Situation für Sie vor Ort wie
sich das für sie anfühlt wir schauen
jetzt aber erstmal zusammen auf eine
Zusammenfassung der Entwicklung vom Tag
von Axel Konrad und Sandra Theiß
viel Zeit zum Packen bleibt Anthony
Garcia nicht Frankreich fliegt seine und
andere EU-Bürger aus Niger aus am
Nachmittag soll die erste Maschine
starten
uns wurde gesagt packt nur das nötigste
in eine kleine Tasche für einen Koffer
ist kein Platz
ein Krisenstab in Paris organisiert die
Evakuierungen Frankreich bietet an auch
deutsche mitzunehmen
vor zwei Tagen hatten Demonstranten die
die neuen Machthaber unterstützen die
französische Botschaft in nieders
Hauptstadt Miami angegriffen Niger war
einst französische Kolonie eine solche
Gefahr für die Deutschen vor Ort sieht
das Auswärtige Amt derzeit nicht rät
aber dazu das französische Angebot
anzunehmen
gestern hatte die westafrikanische
Staatengemeinschaft ecovas in einer
Krisensitzung den pochisten ein
Ultimatum gestellt sie droht mit Gewalt
sollte der abgesetzte Präsident basum
nicht bis Sonntag wieder im Amt sein die
beiden Nachbarländer von Niger Mali und
Burkina Faso wo bereits
Militärregierungen herrschen reagierten
prompt und stellten sich hinter die
putschenden Militärs in Niger bei der
erklärten
wortgleiche Intervention wird als
Kriegserklärung gegen Burkina
der Putsch in Niger betrifft auch den
Abzug der rund 1.000 deutschen Soldaten
aus Mali der sollte über den
lufttransportstützpunkt in niam Mail
laufen wo weitere 100 Bundeswehrsoldaten
stationiert sind dort soll auch ein
Transportflugzeug bereitstehen um im
Notfall deutsche aus Niger rauszubringen
ob das nötig sein wird ist bislang
unklar
über diese Auswirkungen für den
bundeswehrabzug und auch die
Auswirkungen für Deutschland Europa da
sprechen wir noch im Verlauf der Sendung
aber jetzt noch mal zur Situation
konkret vor Ort wir haben also gesehen
entlohnt sich Wut gegenüber in dem Falle
jetzt der französischen Botschaft die
Frankreich lässt also jetzt auch seine
Angehörigen Staatsangehörigen Ausfliegen
haben sie diese Situation aber kommen
sehen Sie selbst vor Ort gab es im
Vorfeld auch schon mal solche
Zwischenfälle oder war das jetzt schon
auch im überraschend für sie selbst vor
Ort dass es sich jetzt plötzlich zu
einem Putsch kam er sich diese Wut
entlädt auf den Straßen können Sie das
für uns erklären
genau das ist das kam für uns alle
völlig überraschend also niemand hat
damit gerechnet dass ein Brötchen nieder
stattfindet diese herum Vorfeld gesagt
haben der Niger galt als der Anker im
Sahel für Stabilität gerade in der
Region mit den beiden Nachbarländern
Burkina Faso und Mali die ja bei den
Militärputsch auch erlebt haben es hat
sich nichts abgezeichnet es kam völlig
überraschend dass es ähm in diesen
Ländern und auch mega natürlich Anti
französische Tendenzen gibt's ja das
wissen wir also es gibt ja genug
Gruppierungen im Land jetzt ist ein
angekündigte große Demonstration für
Donnerstag von von von
M62 nennen die sich in die sind
natürlich sehr
gegen Frankreich eingestellt also wir
rechnen auch damit dass wir die gleichen
Bilder wieder sehen werden
nichtsdestotrotz ja wie gesagt wir haben
nicht gerechnet das kam völlig
überraschend für uns
die Außenministerin Deutschlands werbock
hat sich jetzt auch zu Wort gemeldet
hatte diesen Putsch verurteilt verwies
darauf dass Deutschland als Konsequenz
bereits die Entwicklungszusammenarbeit
mit Niger ausgesetzt habe bis also die
Situation denn wieder der Präsident
wieder im Amt sei der demokratisch
gewählte Präsident wenn das jetzt schon
eine Folge ist und das für sie jetzt
natürlich auch zunächst für den Moment
gerade bedeutet sie arbeiten von zu
Hause auch wenngleich sie sagen das
funktioniert ganz gut was bedeutet das
jetzt für ihre Arbeit in der Region und
was sind ihre Sorgen und Befürchtungen
da vielleicht auch
wir sind jetzt nicht direkt von der
Entscheidung der Bundesregierung
betroffen wir haben deutsche
Finanzierung also auch über das BMZ und
das Auswärtige Amt wobei das Auswärtige
Amt die Mittel nicht blockiert beim beim
BMZ geht es vor allen Dingen um die
Mittel wie sie sagen die Entwicklung
Zusammenarbeit treffen das sind aber
nicht die Mittel die wir vom BMZ haben
wir können im Moment weiter arbeiten wir
noch sehr dankbar dafür
dass ich zu Hause bin hat keinerlei
Auswirkungen wir haben im Land drei
weitere Büros in der Region differ also
in der
landschaftsserie Region in der
Landesmittel
braucht die deutschen Soldaten
stationiert waren
wir können im Moment weiter arbeiten
das ist auch sehr gut so
wir ja wir hoffen dass das so bleibt wir
haben alle Geldgeber angeschrieben also
Aktion gegen Hunger hat das gemacht für
uns weniger und wir haben positive
Rückmeldungen so dass die Arbeit weiter
fortgeführt werden kann das ist sehr
wichtig und wie gesagt wir sind sehr
dankbar dafür schauen wir auch noch mal
auf die Karte gemeinsam damit wir alle
noch mal auch sehen können wo jetzt
aktuell dieser Konflikt stattfindet
Niger ist also der letzte ich hatte es
gesagt der war der letzte stabile Start
im Sahel eben eingebettete bei Mali und
Burkina Faso wir sehen es gerade auf der
Karte beide bereits vor Militär regiert
wenn wir uns jetzt die Niger auch in
eingebetteten dieser Region eben
anschauen und auch gerade sie sind ja
vor Ort um eben natürlich in dieser
Region zu helfen was sind denn die
größten Probleme die größten Sorgen für
sie ganz grundsätzlich in Niger in
dieser Region
wir haben im Niger ich habe den
glücklichen Umstand ich habe schon mal
fünf Jahre mega gearbeitet im Jahr 2005
bis Ende 2009
und ich sehe was die Niger betrifft was
unsere Arbeit betrifft wenig Veränderung
die Probleme die der nie gehabt und die
auch von Aktionen gegen den Hunger
die Arbeit von Aktion gegen Hunger ist
natürlich auch diese Probleme
ausgerichtet haben sich im Laufe der
Jahre nicht geändert das ist eine große
Problematik heute
dazugekommen die die Unsicherheit im
Land also durch die verschiedenen
terroristischen Gruppen in diesem Land
gibt die uns natürlich im Zugang zu
unseren günstigsten behindern wir müssen
also immer gucken können wir unsere
tägliche Arbeit tatsächlich aufnehmen
oder gibt es irgendwelche Bewegungen die
das verhindern wir
ja wir hoffen einfach dass dass wir
unsere Arbeit genauso weiter fortführen
können dass die dass die Geldgeber nicht
abspringen ich glaube der [__] als Land
hat es auch verdient dass wir weiter in
den nieder investieren vor allen Dingen
in die Entwicklungszusammenarbeit und
den Niger aus dieser immer
wiederkehrenden Spirale der Nothilfe und
der humanitärenhilfe die wir vor Ort
leisten irgendwann mal rauszubringen
2009 verlassen habe hatte knapp 11
Millionen Einwohner heute sind es mehr
als 26 Millionen in dieser Kurzzeit
dieses enormes Wachstum bestellt den
Sieger natürlich auch vor große
Herausforderungen ein Land
ja das sind kurze Zeit so so wächst so
anwächst ja wir müssen einfach gucken
wie wir wie wir auch die
Ernährungssicherheit in den Griff
bekommen und das ist eben auch die
Arbeit von Aktion gegen Hunger und wir
hoffen ganz einfach das klare
stabilisiert und dass wir alle anderen
Partnern vor Ort unsere Arbeit weiter
fortführen können
sagt Wert der uns live aus dem [__]
zugeschaltet ist vielen Dank dass Sie
sich heute extra für uns Zeit genommen
haben danke ihn
[Musik]
und wir können ich habe es eben
angesprochen jetzt in dieser Sendung auf
jeden Fall jetzt hier an diesem Moment
auch jetzt mal schauen aber auf diese
Evakuierungsaktion die Frankreich
gestartet hat ob davon jetzt eben auch
deutsche Gebrauch machen werden es sind
knapp 100 deutsche Zivilisten die sich
aktuell Niger befinden sollen also eine
kleinere Gruppe und ihnen wurde eben nun
geraten auszureisen wir können jetzt
darüber sprechen mit unserem
Hauptstadtstudio Korrespondenten Andreas
kühners ist uns jetzt live aus Berlin
zugeschaltet hallo Andreas hallo Andreas
von dieser Gruppe wir haben es eben
gerade gehört das sind nicht sehr viele
aber dennoch also fast 100 Menschen wer
kann wird da jetzt überhaupt rausgehen
und wenn ja wie was hast du dafür
Informationen heute aus Berlin also die
Reisewarnung die das Auswärtige Amt
ausgesprochen hat gilt für alle
deutschen Staatsbürger minus muss man
sagen - Die deutschen Diplomaten und -
die Soldaten die noch sind in
Niger wie viele Deutsche davon Gebrauch
machen werden ist die Frage weil man
natürlich auch hier in Berlin davon
ausgeht dass deutsche Staatsbürger die
im Niger leben dass die schon ich sag
mal ziemlich hart sind im Nehmen und wir
haben es ja auch gerade von Herrn Robak
Wert im gehört dass er und seine
Mitarbeiter dort bleiben wollen also es
wird eine relativ kleine Zahl sein davon
geht man aus in Berlin die die
Aufforderung die der Aufforderung
nachkommen Niger zu verlassen und
deswegen verzichtet eben auch
Deutschland zum Beispiel auf eine eigene
evakuierungsmission deswegen sagt das
Auswärtige Amt leute bitte nimmt das
Angebot der Franzosen an die ja gesagt
haben wir nehmen deutsche und andere
EU-Bürger mit auf unsere Flüge und da
geht man im Moment davon aus wenn Berlin
dass das reicht das dass keine deutsche
Mission nötig sein wird die deutschen
Diplomaten und es gibt die deutsche
Botschaft ist anders als die
französische Botschaft bisher nicht Ziel
geworden von Ausschreitungen sie ist
aber vorsichtshalber verlegt worden an
einen sicheren Ort in der Hauptstadt an
den Flughafen
wo auch die deutschen Soldaten sind und
da gibt es im Moment keine Pläne zu
evakuieren da ist im Moment der Stand
wir halten unser Personal dort für
sicher die deutsche Botschaft bleibt
also offen auch wenn sie verlegt wurde
aber trotzdem es steht ein deutscher
Flieger am Flughafen in Niamey der steht
da bereit warum ist der denn oder wofür
ist der dann vorgesehen warum ist der
dort das ist der Notausgang
man beobachtet die Lage hier sehr genau
in Berlin und man muss natürlich auch
einräumen dass man von diesem Putsch und
von dieser ganzen Entwicklung in nieder
total überrascht war und deswegen das
soll nicht noch mal passieren deswegen
steht dieser Flieger da der hat seine
400m und der hat genau die Kapazität
alle deutschen Soldaten alle deutschen
Diplomaten und vielleicht auch noch ein
paar übrig gebliebene deutsche die dann
noch ausreisen wollen mitzunehmen
deswegen steht ja da für den schlimmsten
Fall von dem keiner hofft dass er
passiert aber man will vorbereitet sein
und nicht noch einmal im von so einer
Entwicklung überrascht werden du hast
auch schon die Bundeswehrsoldaten
angesprochen die sind also auch dort vor
Ort in Niger bleiben also auch zunächst
vor Ort die koordinieren nämlich den
Abzug der Soldaten aus Mali also dem
Nachbarland wir haben es vorhin auf
einer Karte ja gesehen ist das jetzt
davon beeinträchtigt dieser Abzug aus
Mali was bedeutet das jetzt für diese
Aktion also dieser Lufttransport
Stützpunkt der ist unglaublich wichtig
nicht nur für den Abzug aus Mali aber
auch
die Deutschen haben ja gesagt sie ziehen
aus Mali ab und in Mali steht jede Menge
Gerät teures Gerät Gerät das auch
Geheimnis das nicht in ähm falsche Hände
fallen soll und jeder Tag an dem es
jetzt nicht ausgeflogen werden kann der
kann nicht aufgeholt werden also
deswegen es müssen bereits jetzt in Mali
militärische Sachen zerstört werden
gesprengt werden damit sie nicht nach
dem Abzug in falsche Hände fallen das
sind Bilder die so ein bisschen auch an
die Situation in Afghanistan erinnern
obwohl das natürlich insgesamt politisch
nicht vergleichbar ist aber das wollte
man eigentlich nicht noch mal und man
hat gesagt alles gut alles kein Problem
wir gehen ja über unseren
lufttransportstützpunkt in Niger raus
wir schaffen das auch in der Zeit das
ist jetzt schon nicht mehr zu halten und
deswegen ist die Bundesregierung gerade
im Gespräch mit anderen Ländern mit
Nachbarländern des Niger und versucht
ganz schnell Verträge zu schließen dass
man das Material aus Mali über diese
Länder zum Beispiel über Algerien
rausschafft aber das dauert Zeit das
dauert Diplomatie und das ist alles
ja sehr schwierig und das ist eigentlich
für Deutschland das eigentliche Drama an
dieser Situation gerade und Deutschland
hat ja auch geholfen die frische
Spezialkräfte auszubilden hatte also
auch natürlich Zeit und auch viel Geld
Jahre lang investiert ist das jetzt
alles umsonst wie geht das weiter es
liegt das alles jetzt brav
ja das liegt brach das ist eine
riesengroße Katastrophe im Prinzip ist
die ganze Sahel Strategie der
Bundesregierung seit letzter Woche in
Trümmern von allen Staaten der Sahelzone
du hast es ja auch schon öfter gesagt
war Niger der einzige das einzige Land
das doch so ein bisschen Hoffnung
verbreitet hatte dem es demokratische
Wahlen gab in dem es eine demokratische
Regierung gab und im Prinzip ist in den
vergangenen Jahren jeder Deutsche
Außenpolitiker immer wieder nach
niedergefahren in den niedergefahren
Kanzlerin Merkel die ganzen
Verteidigungsminister Kanzler Scholz war
gerade erst da weil es eben so ein
hoffnungsstaat war und Deutschland hat
nicht nur Jahre investiert und viele
Hoffnung investiert das hat auch sehr
viel Geld investiert und
selbst wenn sage ich mal der Präsident
bei so nun doch wieder eingesetzt werden
sollte durch politischen Druck
vielleicht auch durch eine militärische
Intervention ist natürlich die Frage
hier die man sich hier in Berlin stellt
wie viel Autorität hätte der dann
überhaupt also das ist wieder so wird
wie vorher glaubt in Berlin niemand und
das ist wirklich eine sehr sehr
schlechte Nachricht für die ganze Region
und auch für Deutschland
die ganze Region wir wollen auch jetzt
über die Auswirkungen für die gesamte
Region sprechen im weiteren Verlauf der
Sendung sagen jetzt aber erstmal danke
an Andreas Künast und sagt Korrespondent
im Hauptstadtstudio in Berlin vielen
Dank
gern und jetzt geht es nämlich darum ich
habe auch schon eure Fragen dazu gesehen
viele Fragen zur Lage vor Ort zur
Entwicklung des Putsches vor Ort und
auch natürlich was bedeutet das jetzt
was hat das für Auswirkungen für
Deutschland für Europa aber eben auch
für die Menschen vor Ort in der Region
das können wir jetzt vertiefen Simone
Schnabel ist bei uns jetzt zugeschaltet
sie forscht am Leibniz-Institut
hessische Stiftung Friedens und
Konfliktforschung und sie forscht zur
Erhaltung von Frieden und Sicherheit auf
dem afrikanischen Kontinent kennt sich
also bestens in der Region aus hallo
Frau Schnabel schön dass Sie da sind
Frau Schnabel wir haben es eben gerade
gehört nieder ist auch ein wichtiger
Partner gewesen insbesondere für
Deutschland aber auch in Europa es gibt
ein Kommentar bei uns im Stream bei
Youtube Paul D schreibt in Afghanistan
waren am Ende auch alle überrascht
irgendwie immer das gleiche hat man die
die die die Dynamik in dem Land hat man
die so falsch eingeschätzt einfach nicht
gesehen was da gerade wirklich passiert
ja mit den politischen Entwicklungen in
den Nachbarländern des Liga also
insbesondere wo Kinder Faso und mehr
noch in Malibu sozusagen der Großteil
des internationalen Engagements
stattfand
musste man dieses Engagement dieses
Zusammenarbeit neu ausrichten und konnte
nicht mehr mit dem Putschregierung in
Mali und Burkina Faso zusammenarbeiten
mega geil auch als sogenannter
Stabilitätsanker bei einem Vergleich zu
den Nachbarländern die Gewalt geringer
ist
und darüber hinaus
wurde auch die niedrige Regierung von
Seiten der Bundesregierung schon länger
als ja verlässlicher Partner
wertgeschätzt durchaus auch aus guten
Gründen also ehrliche Bemühungen auch
von Seiten der Regierung die
Gewaltprobleme anzugehen anders als in
den Nachbarländern war beispielsweise
der jetzt bestürzte Präsident auch in
den Regionen sehr viel präsenter
hat es auch geschafft ethnische
Minderheiten in den Staatsapparat zu
integrieren
dennoch denke ich hat man die Fragilität
der Institution und insbesondere das
militärapparats unterschätzt und das
zieht sich auch durch die anderen Länder
das sind einfach sehr fragile Gebilde in
denen es um Macht Kämpfe geht gespalten
wir haben auch Kinder gesehen
zweiten Putsch das sozusagen ein ein
Militär aus der regulären Armee gegen
die präsidial gerade
gepusht hat und entsprechend so sehen
wir das jetzt auch im Liga also
die der ehemalige Vorsitzende oder Chef
der präsidialgarde
Elite core
Militärs hat sozusagen Regierung
gestürzt und ich denke auch man hat
vielleicht auch die Krise der Demokratie
unterschätzt weil
zwar ist bei Zoom mit dem quatschen Wein
an die Macht gekommen aber die Erfahrung
der nigranten der Demokratie sind doch
vor allen Dingen ernüchternde Erfahrung
sie hat in der Bilanz die
Lebenssituation der Menschen kaum
verbessert sondern ja sie hat sich in
den letzten Jahren eigentlich noch
weiter verschärft daran hat natürlich
auch die Krise aber auch der russische
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine zu tun und
die ja durchaus massive Präsenz
ausländischer Akteure konnte auch daran
nichts ändern und vielleicht müssen wir
auch noch mal Detail so ein bisschen auf
die Entwicklung dieses Putsches und auch
ja warum gibt es eigentlich diesen
Putsch gerade eingehen was wir gesehen
haben jetzt in den letzten Tagen waren
schon das Tausende auch die Militär da
ihre Unterstützung zu gesichert haben in
nieder selbst und dann und das war ganz
spannend in den Bildern ich habe dazu
auch mehrere Fragen jetzt gerade im Chat
gesehen es warten russische Flaggen
während das Protest also russische
Flaggen beten während des Protests in
Niger vor der französischen Botschaft
und dazu gibt es Fragen bei uns im
Stream also einmal fragt sich eine
Userin ein User was steckt denn
eigentlich hinter dem Putsch und wir
nutzt der und daran anschließend von
Stefan Dahlmann auch die Frage bei
Youtube mich würde mal interessieren um
was es in dem Konflikt überhaupt geht
warum putscht das Militär hat Russland
da die Finger im Spiel wenn man jetzt
diese Fahnen sieht dann liegt das ja
irgendwie auch ein bisschen nah können
Sie uns da mal aufklären
ja in der Tat sind diese Bilder aus der
Hauptstadt niami gerade sehr präsent in
den internationalen Medien man muss man
sagen ja mir ist die Hochburg der
Opposition also dort durchaus auch
Unterstützung auf der Straße gibt für
die Militärs liegt eben auch daran dass
bei Zoomen dort weniger Anhänger hat
gleichzeitig gibt es auch davon erfahren
wir natürlich sehr viel weniger
Demonstrationen in anderen Landesteilen
insbesondere dort wo eben versuchen
seine Anhänger und Anhänger hat also
gerade extrem schwierig
ein Bild herzustellen zu wissen was was
denken die migra und über über diese
Entwicklung allerdings
gibt es bisher keine Anzeichen dass
Russland hinter dem Rutsch steht oder
auch das Russland neuer Partner einer
gegebenenfalls Militärregierung weniger
würde das ist anders als beispielsweise
in Mali und ich denke
wir dürfen uns von diesen russischen
Flaggen insofern nicht verleiten lassen
dass sie vor allen Dingen Ausdruck Anti
französischer Reis und die sind dass sie
Ausdruck der Umstrittenheit der
Militärpräsenz Frankreichs als alter
Kolonialmacht sind und dass dahinter
noch nicht unbedingt russische
Sympathien stehen wir wissen allerdings
auch noch nicht die sich sozusagen das
im weiteren entwickeln wird aber ich
denke es ist ganz wichtig diese Bilder
die wir aus der Hauptstadt hier in
Deutschland sehen sind nicht
die mein ung der Nikon und gerade da
ich User Sven Odenwald der schreibt bei
Facebook allerdings welche Rolle spielen
die Wagner sollten aber der dies
Stabilisierung afrikanischer Staaten
denn auch die sind ja immer wieder in
dieser Region auch unterwegs gewesen
also ist da sogar keine Verbindung da
noch mal nachgehakt bei ihnen zu
Russland da also weil es wenig ja eben
auch diese russischen Fahnen das müssen
wir vielleicht noch mal ganz deutlich
hier machen
Wagner spielt vor allen Dingen in
malinrolle dort hat kooperiert die
malische transitionsregierung mit
wagnergruppierung insbesondere in
Zentral Mali aber wie ich bereits gesagt
habe
im Moment gibt es keine Anzeichen dass
das Russland irgendeinen Einfluss auf
diese Entwicklungen gehabt hätte oder
das eine sozusagen Kooperation mit
wagnergruppen in nieder aussteht und ich
denke da müssen wir auch unterscheiden
die durchaus auch die innenpolitischen
Motive der Kutsche und auch die Historie
der Kutsche in den Ländern also
beispielsweise und auch besonders die
Unterschiede also in Mali ist mit dem
Putsch monatelange Massendemonstrationen
die den Rücktritt das damals Präsidenten
gefordert haben das haben wir so wieder
nicht gesehen entsprechend überraschend
kam eben auch der Putsch für viele
lokale internationale Akteuren
Beobachter
dennoch gibt es im nieder durchaus auch
eine Geschichte
von rutschen die die Demokratie
verteidigt haben nämlich dann wenn
demokratische demokratisch gewählte
macht in Thema versucht haben eben diese
Macht auszunutzen und beispielsweise bei
Verfassungsänderungen eine dritte
Amtszeit sich zu sichern
und schauen wir noch mal auf die ganz
aktuellen Entwicklungen auf der letzten
Tage und heute denn am Sonntag hatte die
westafrikanische Wirtschaftsgemeinschaft
die heißt ecovas die hatte dem Militär
Niger ein Ultimatum gesetzt eben gesagt
also solange die abgesetzte Regierung
nicht wieder eingesetzt wird dann würden
sie mit Konsequenzen drohen das ganze
sollte innerhalb von einer Woche
passieren sonst würden so hieß es alle
Optionen in Betracht gezogen
einschließlich des Einsatzes von Gewalt
und zudem verhängte eben dieser
Staatenbund Sanktionen gegen Niger jetzt
gibt es hier eine Frage auch bei uns im
Stream von icke bei Youtube er fragt
sich oder sie soll die EU gemeinsam mit
der ecovas das ist eben diese
westafrikanische Wirtschaftsgemeinschaft
militärisch intervenieren um den
Präsidenten zu befreien sollte das
passieren die sehen Sie das Denken sie
das ist nur Option oder droht sonst auch
wirklich ein Krieg in dieser gesamten
Region
ist ein zentraler Akteur in der
wirklichen Beilegung dieses Konflikts
wir haben gesehen die Staatschefs der
Ecowas haben am Wochenende mit Härte
reagiert und ein
Ultimatum von nur einer Woche gestellt
das ist durchaus nicht der Norm die Norm
sind eigentlich 14 Tage und sie haben
vor allen Dingen mit militärischen
Interventionen Meditation getrunken
neben anderen Maßnahmen gegen pochisten
der Einsatz militärische Mittel kam
zuletzt 2016 und 2017 in der regionalen
Intervention in Gambia vor
insofern ist es durchaus
ernst zu nehmen mit welcher vehements
Deko was sie reagiert und ich denke ja
daraufhin haben sich auch der Ton
internationaler Partner verhärtet die
ähm das Besondere daraufhin die
Zusammenarbeit zu spendiert haben
man beginnt mit Erwerbungen obwohl ja
vor Ort ja wenig darauf hindeutet dass
tatsächlich eine Gefahr
für von Gewalt für eben
aus den Charaktere vor Ort gibt dennoch
diese anthrung auch von gegengewaltigt
neu in der Region das bisher so nicht
und
ich denke aber dennoch und das hat man
jetzt auch in den letzten Tagen gesehen
es sind noch nicht alle zivilen Mittel
ausgeschöpft und die Eco was wird
weiterhin versuchen eine
Mitteln eine
Lösung
zu verhandeln
gleichzeitig denke ich kann diese Lösung
aber nur darauf sich darauf verschränken
dass bei zoomen und weitere
Regierungsmitglieder die in den letzten
Tagen verhaftet wurden
freigelassen werden ich halte eine
Rückkehr war so in das am Präsidenten
für ihr unwahrscheinlich welche
Auswirkungen glauben sie hat diese
Situation jetzt für die Region aber eben
auch für Europa könnte das jetzt zu mehr
Fluchtbewegung führen von Menschen die
diese Region wenn sie so instabil noch
instabiler wird jetzt verlassen wollen
was ist da ihre Einschätzung
ja wir sehen an den Entwicklungen in der
Nachbarländern und insbesondere Burkina
Faso dass die Gewalt zunimmt nicht
abnimmt also man kann auch mega davon
ausgehen dass die Gewalt weiter zunehmen
wird dass
terroristische Gruppierungen die
Situation auch ausnutzen können um ihren
Einflussgebiet zu vergrößern
ich denke das wird vor allen Dingen dazu
führen dass noch mehr Menschen auf der
Flucht sind allerdings vor allen Dingen
binnenvertrieben im eigenen Land in die
Nachbarländer also es geht ja nicht um
Flucht nach Europa sondern
insbesondere in sozusagen der Nachbar
der Regionen und auch benachbarte Länder
insbesondere den Küstenländern das heißt
humanitären Bedarfe in der Region die
schon sehr hoch sind werden weiter
steigen
und zum Schluss aber noch mal dann auch
eine Frage von dem User der Userin icke
die hatte ich eben schon mal aber auch
spannend die Frage eben jetzt auch
gerade zum Ende was kann denn die
internationale Gemeinschaft jetzt noch
tun um dieser hält Zone zu stabilisieren
was kann jetzt noch getan werden wenn er
jetzt natürlich auch die Bemühungen der
letzten Jahre zumindest in Niger
gescheitert scheinen
ja ich denke im Moment
muss man erstmal die Entwicklung vor Ort
abwarten sehen inwieweit man mit ich
hatte ja schon gesagt ich hatte aber
sonst eher für unwahrscheinlich also
inwieweit
man Konditionen für eine
Militärregierung vielleicht verhandeln
kann insbesondere auch wie man weiter
vielleicht
Zusammenarbeit fortsetzen kann wir haben
eben auch schon gehört es gibt auf jeden
Fall eine große Bereitschaft weiterhin
von der Bundesregierung der griechischen
Bevölkerung
insbesondere auch in der Ernährungskrise
zu unterstützen
ich denke was aber notwendig sein wird
ist
auch die bisherigen Ansätze die verfolgt
wurden in den Berührungen den seinen
Ländern in der Stabilisierung und in der
Ausbreitung der Gewalt
ja inwieweit diese Bemühungen
erfolgreich waren und
sich ehrlich zu fragen welche Ansätze
haben Zukunft und was haben wir
vielleicht was hat die Bundesregierung
die internationalen Partner
vielleicht auch versäumt
auch genügend zu berücksichtigen
sagt Simone Schnabel vom
Leibniz-Institut hessische Stiftung
friedens- und Konfliktforschung vielen
Dank für Ihre Einschätzung heute Abend
und dass sie bei uns waren
und vielen Dank natürlich auch an euch
für eure Fragen für eure Kommentare ich
hoffe wir konnten hier ein paar offene
Fragen klären und wir freuen uns wenn
ihr das nächste Mal wieder dabei seid
und sagen Danke vom gesamten Team heute
von ZDF heute live macht's gut tschüss
[Musik]